let's bring in peter king football
morning in America also works for
football night in America but that great
column is available every Monday
exclusively on NBC sports.com Peter good
morning how are you good morning Dan how
you doing I'm doing okay trying to
figure out what direction the Redskins
go in and is that a coveted job I mean
Dan Snyder and Bruce Allen will tell you
how wonderful the job is but all you had
to do was look at the crowds the last
couple of home games one of the
Washington Post guys did a really cool
thing he he took a photo and tweeted it
out yesterday of the people leaving the
metro stop that's about I don't know
maybe a quarter-mile maybe even less
than you know away from FedEx Field and
it was amazing
all of them were wearing either Brady or
Edelman jerseys it was a teeming number
of people and and if he watched any of
the game which I didn't but I saw some
highlights and you looked in the stands
the stands that were not empty just were
either it had to be half Patriots fans
at that game yesterday and so look
they'll say it's a coveted job then but
here's the biggest problem I think they
have is that nobody nobody trusts who's
picking the players there is widespread
belief that the owner picked Dewayne
Haskins which is his right he owns the
team and doing Haskins was a good
prospect no question about it and no one
has any idea if Dwayne Haskins is you
know going to be a player or not so
there will be a certain number of people
who say hey it's one of 32 I'll go coach
the Bengals you know I'll code I'll
coach Washington it's fine I if I get
one of the opportunities you want to 32
give it to new so somebody will be
excited about taking that job but I
would say the majority of people who are
very confident in their future let's
just say for the sake of argument like a
Josh McDaniels or a any one of the guys
out there who is a prime candidate
- at some point in the next couple of
years get a job I would be surprised if
they were very interested in this job
unless and I'll underlying this unless
they're big fans and really really like
Dewayne Haskins coming out last spring
serious question do you think you could
do a better job running the Redskins as
GM I think if I had the right staff I
think that I could do a good job running
an NFL team but that's that that has to
do with you know what the owner actually
lets you do
how many analytics people would he let
me bring and how many people would allow
I how many people with the owner and the
people who run the team how many people
would that owner allowed to be brought
on because I think it takes a village
Dan it absolutely unequivocally takes a
village you have to be able to say I
want to bring in X number the following
people and I would say twenty years ago
I would have gone at this with hook line
and sinker but today I'm 62 years old I
kind of like my Mondays and Tuesdays off
right now and so you're not going to
you're not going to rebuild an NFL
franchise if if if you like to take a
couple of days every week off in the
fall which I now do so what you're
saying is you're removing your name from
consideration we've had back-to-back
subpar performances by dak Prescott does
that hurt his negotiations at all
well I believe I sound like Gary Jones
well I believe you know I really believe
that what's happening here is the deck
Prescott essentially is saying to the
Dallas Cowboys hey listen I will bet on
myself this is a Joe Flacco
13 situation where remember when Joe
Flacco's said hey listen you know house
he knew so I wanted to get him signed to
a new contract and all that and he said
I'm gonna be done at the end of this
year and you know I just want to wait
and see what happens he's like mookie
betts with the Red Sox hey nothing
personal
I don't dislike anybody there I want a
sign I want to be there but but honestly
what I want to do is just wait and see
what my real value is at the end of my
contract there's nothing wrong with that
and look I'm not even saying that that
Prescott exactly wants to do that but I
think that dak Prescott looks at the
market and he says I cannot lose by
waiting and I think he's right I mean is
value hasn't been helped the last two
weeks because he has been mediocre in
the team offensively mostly has been
lousy you don't fall behind at home 31 2
3 or to a playoff contender and think
that life is good so I it hasn't helped
but I don't think it's hurt him that
much he's Peter King his great column
every Monday morning football morning in
America avail available on NBC
sports.com Christian McCaffrey has been
unbelievable you could make the case
that through five weeks he's been the
MVP but what is your biggest concern
about how Carolina is using Christian
McCaffrey well you know you just look at
his body and he's an absolute piece of
granite you know I spent a little time
with him a training camp and and look
he's he is he concentrates so much on
having the perfect body but so many of
those guys work out religiously and do
everything religiously to get very good
and to get strong and all that and we've
seen it time and time again how the
overuse of running backs the number of
hits that running backs take basically
end up you know affecting the longevity
of their career that's the thing I'd be
worried about and I don't have any I
don't have any worries whatsoever that a
few X
carries here and there are going to
affect him that much but I just have a
worry that if they go on this trail of
making him
Minoo a 25 to 30 touch guy every week
which they haven't done yet MA but if
they do that it was the longevity of his
career would would worry me and I think
he'd be a lot less like a Frank Gore
then he would you know the guys who's
whose career and say prematurely are in
there in their late 20s where do you
rank the Green Bay Packers with NFC
teams this year I would probably put
them right now I mean is to two teams
that I think when I look at them I'm so
impressed and I keep saying to myself
well let's keep them let's see them keep
doing it one of them is Green Bay and
the other one is Seattle and I think
both of them obviously you know have
been great so far and it isn't that Oh
show me more but I think right now with
Green Bay as I look at them what has
impressed me so much and I don't want to
say it's seamless but the transition
from Mike McCarthy to Matt Lafleur I
think has been energizing for Aaron
Rodgers and I think that they have
learned that they can be a little bit
pissy with each other and it'll be okay
and that's the thing that has impressed
me most and the fact that Brian kukuda
comes the general manager totally did a
180 from what Ted Thompson did when he
built the team because when gudykunst
this offseason what he ended up doing
was spending a jillion dollars to buy a
pass rough it's a classic old Washington
maneuver you know and it worked I mean I
should say so far it's worked because
the Darius Smith and Preston Smith
you know it's amazing to me especially
in a case of Preston Smith that
Washington would let him go because of
obviously they have need to cross the
board and they let him go and he has
been an absolute gem as has a Darius
Smith so I think they've got the right
formula right now where Aaron Rodgers
knows he doesn't have to go out every
week and put up 30 how surprised were
you with the cold stood last night I was
really surprised but I talked to Frank
Reich around midnight and and he said
that on Saturday Saturday night at the
meeting he said he told me that you know
they've had 23 games in the Frank Gregg
era and in those 23 games he said I
never felt better entering a game I
never felt better after practice than I
did about this one and he said you know
a lot of times you hear coach speak and
a coach might say that but he said I'm
just telling you I don't do that stuff
and I told these guys last night that it
will you know everybody out there is
going to be shocked when we when we win
this game but the people in this room
will not be shocked and he just said to
me he said I'm just it sounds real cocky
when you say something like that but
absolutely surprise it won't happen out
there today so you know we'll see I
think what they have done that nobody
will pay attention to after last night
Frank Wright came in and he said we want
to build a top five running game and so
last year they were 20th 20th in the NFL
in rushing because when you have Andrew
Luck and you have a guy who's thrown 39
touchdown passes well why wouldn't you
build your offense around the
quarterback but this year they said
we're going to have a complementary
quarterback in Jacoby perset we've got a
great offensive line and we're just
going to possess the ball and we're
going to cram it down people's throats
and last night about seven minutes left
in the game Jacoby perset went to Frank
Reich on the side
and said I'm quoting almost verbatim hey
let's just run it let's go shove it down
their throats and that's what they ended
up doing it's not a sexy thing everybody
would rather have Jacobi per said
throwing four for ten but it works and
it still works in football today that
you can run in Lent
I'll leave you with this browns Niners
tonight the importance of this game more
for the Browns or the Niners well as I
look at it right now I mean it still
looks like the Ravens are going to be
the team to beat in that division even
though the Browns you know have a you
know have the one game in hand and the
early tiebreaker and all that but then I
think the thing that would concern me if
I were Cleveland looking at the
landscape is there's a bunch of games
for us that are going to be really hard
to win going forward you know they got
no England and all that and they get a
bunch of tough games but I think that
Cleveland is being built right now the
right way where we just talked about the
running game I mean they've got Nick
Chubb and he showed that last week that
he can dominate a game imagine what
happens when they get Nick Chubb in
Korean and they don't have to survive on
the whims and the inconsistencies a very
young quarterback like Baker Mayfield I
think this is a bigger game quite
honestly for the 49ers
just because I look at the Rams and I
look at Seattle as so formidable in that
division that they've got to keep up
with the Joneses and any game that that
they've got a chance to win I mean it's
important that they keep stacking wins
Peter thank you great column as always
we appreciate your time thank you I
appreciate it Dan that's Peter King
football morning in America every Monday
exclusively on NBC sports.com for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]